how about we uh we jump over to um
bloomberg trying to buy the floor to
vote
mia bloomberg so in this next story from
the daily mail is bloomberg trying to
buy the florida vote
billionaire pays off more than 20
million dollars in debt for 31 000
felons
so they can vote in the state where just
537 votes decided the presidential
election in 2000
wow is it a dirty move to give people
the right to vote no
that's my initial thought no way
liberate
but he's a rich guy he's he's putting
his thumb on the scale that's what we
should use our money for is to help the
people that are stuck then why don't we
just tell them they can vote oh
well we'd have to change the law to do
that yeah so i don't know what you think
is this is this playing dirty or is this
the right the right move yeah i mean it
strikes me as playing dirty but i have
obvious biases here i know that he's
just trying to get somebody elected who
i very much don't like i'm trying to
think how i would feel if it was uh
somebody doing that because they thought
it would get a republican elected and if
i'd feel any different about it
to me i've become more and more wary of
people just using massive amounts of
money to try to influence political
change but
on the other hand i'm sure if i had
billions of dollars i would probably
attempt to do the same thing so
it's difficult for me to say one way or
the other i'm sorry i'm being a bit of a
fence sitter here on this one but
it's something i need to give this
thought to because i just heard this
story today
so i haven't really had time to fully
put together my opinion how many how
many right-wing people are dumping tons
of money in to do similar things like
this but donald trump yeah yeah
legit question like how many do you know
i i don't know of anything because i've
heard of like
we've all heard of the koch brothers the
my pillow guy the my pillow guy oh he's
the biggest you know
those pillows no i mean he does fun like
like tucker carlson
yeah yeah sound them pill selling them
pillows but uh the mercers as well have
been like their name has popped up
but it feels like there's way more
left-wing rich people
isn't that interesting yeah it's just
very intellectually fashionable in their
circles and it's funny because
we know that they said they were not
gonna like disney for example wasn't
gonna film in georgia anymore because of
the heartbeat bill
they said they could not in good
conscience i believe maybe this wasn't
their exact language but the idea was
they could never film an estate that
limited a woman's right to choose
uh to kill an unborn child and then they
went and they filmed in china where
there are uyghur concentrations
security forces that were enforcing it
and and some people are saying oh well
they're complete hypocrites
i think it's even more insidious than
that they know that they're never going
to be able to influence chinese policy
they know who the higher authority is
there but they believe that they can put
economic pressure on georgia to change
its laws
who are these people this is disney
they've they they
which is and they're gonna dmca this are
you talking about georgia georgia the
state or the country
no the state of georgia yeah yeah they
said they wouldn't film there because of
the
pro-life ruling or it was it was a
heartbeat bill saying if there was a
heartbeat you cannot abort
wow so so politically expedient when
it's expedient but
fiscal when it's fiscal is that why it's
fake it's because
china has money and that no one china is
going to comply and no one in america is
going to complain about china so they
get away with it
yep this is this is like this everything
we're seeing is what happens
when there is no check on one political
faction
so the left controls all they have a
monopoly on the culture so they've gone
insane
it nothing makes sense it's all just
purely insane
and the republicans don't have a
monopoly on government so i thought
i find it really funny when the left
says you know uh i'm i'm the counter
culture revolutionary resistance woohoo
donald trump is bad and i'm like yeah
the other republicans control the
presidency in the senate
that's powerful but like the left has
all culture colleges tv video games
everything movies what about like
uh like foreign oligarchs that are
funneling money through panama
that are helping i don't even know who
they're helping are they helping the
republicans
are they funding no probably not i mean
if you want if you want
uh to set up if you want people setting
up factories in your country where they
pay dirt wages to
you know in sweatshops then trump's not
your guy
trump's the guy who's like bring the
factories back we we already know that
let me see if this is working i don't
think it's working are we working at all
yeah yeah there we go
so we already know that russia is
favoring trump right
and then china is favoring um this is
correct
because biden is not going to be the one
who brings the jobs back to the u.s
no jo biden's going to be the one who
brings them back to china right yeah
well what about this what if russia
spent 47 thousand dollars on facebook
ads mostly unrelated to the election and
it changed american democracy forever
like that's what happened change
democracy i love how like that was this
big smoke
and it wasn't even russia it was russian
companies right it wasn't even actually
a russian government
but going back to that gang stalking
thing right where people think they're
being targeted
have you ever been called a russian bot
uh i have not yet i've been called worse
things but
i'm i'm sure at some point it's a really
common thing you'll see people be like
you're a bot you're a russian bot
you're just about you're not real
everyone's a robot they're they're all
girls
we can call you the timbot yet no that
was what they just when elon musk
plugs us in and does the neural link
we're all going to be russian bots
it's going to be great when we look at
the neural link and then you know
everyone just knows what everyone else
is thinking oh yeah that sounds
fantastic
i kind of like it i hate it really yeah
you have to have
some privacy they're gonna it's not
gonna work because what if someone hacks
your neural link
exactly and then what does that what
does that mean like what did the neural
link do to the pigs like what was he
doing
it didn't look like i had any adverse
effects no but like what was they were
measuring like activity in the frontal
lobe
they found all of the pig's most
embarrassing thoughts and then told its
friends
yeah you need to go deeper into the
brain to get that stuff um
the threads are too thick right now but
it was measuring like what they were
smelling was translating into
electrical impulses into different areas
and then they could read like
kind of read what they were smelling i
think i saw a long time ago about
probably like maybe three or four years
ago i saw a video about this little
device they made
that they hook up to a cockroach's
antennas and it puts electrical signals
to them which
makes the cockroach move in certain
directions based on what it thinks
it's sensing yeah and it was like i
guess a little toy that they were like
using with remote control to move the
roach around which is really freaky
and i think one of the scientists was
discussing and i watched a couple of
videos on it and they were doing
experiments with beetles and they said
that
they could tell that there were signals
in the brain attempting to fight
the electrical signals yeah so yeah it
wasn't even as if
this this uh yeah yeah it was actually
fighting against the brain but still
making
them do it is that the future yeah well
so i don't know i was actually watching
something about
how i don't know exactly what it was i
was reading something about how if they
your equilibrium or uh you know the
stuff in your ears that like helps keep
balance
oh yeah yeah they could alter your sense
of balance so you're standing perfectly
still but you feel like you're falling
backwards so you start
trying to move forward and they could
control your movements by tricking your
brain's balance
so you like whatever you know yeah dude
it's going to make people control bots
that have super abilities and you're
gonna i just hope it all collapses if we
if we could ever get to that point i
would
i would like to think industrial society
would just collapse before then well
hold on hold on
let's say there's somebody who's a
violent murderer right
first let me ask your honest opinion
what do you do with a violent murderer
you catch them they're caught they're
subdued they're cuffed are in the back
of a car what do we do
really bad murder really yeah yeah i
mean bring them off to prison
and then just pay for them to live in
prison forever
yeah i mean i think if a society has the
resources to sustain
somebody like that without having to
kill them you should keep them alive
and so let's operate under the under the
assumption that this guy
says i'll never stop ha ha if you let me
out i'll kill again
and what are you the option to give him
a neural link instead
and then just disable murder murderous
rampage
yeah that's an interesting thought
because it's so
it's so hypothetical and what you're
talking about is taking a person's free
will but of course when we put somebody
in prison we're taking their freedom
but then again yeah but we're also not
taking away their ability to make
choices that's that's really complicated
because because then you start to get
into the question of what about the the
different
drugs that we give people to regulate
their mood does that in some way take
your free will from you
because you're modifying the way that
your brain works obviously that's a very
different example but there's a spectrum
some drugs we would agree do take your
free will you're just not really able to
function on them and make
decisions you would make otherwise
whereas some drugs not as much
like you know like with um a drug you
might be um
prescribed for for depression or anxiety
or something will
have different effects on on your brain
than than others than maybe like hard
street drugs but then the question is
yeah at what point do you
reach the limit i don't know i think the
the bigger fear i have it's
so i i understand the idea i'm not
necessarily a fan if you have like a
violent murderer or
a pedo or something they'll never change
you put a neural link you click a button
boom gone that those all those behaviors
are removed where's the line and who
controls it that's the scary thing
yeah so let's say you end up as a right
winger
and they're like oh let's get rid of
that let's get rid of that and then what
happens is
the reason why i'm i'm really skeptical
on the neural link stuff is
you might get the neural link thinking
it's gonna be great i can connect to the
internet and just think i can play video
games i can literally
go into skyrim world like have this
thing into my brain it's amazing
and then someone can hack into your
brain and be like let's make this person
a murderer and they think they're a duck
and then you're going to be like running
around going i'm like bashing your face
into people
like do you want to give someone access
to your brain through the internet no
yeah so so do you guys know about um
like uh pacemakers and like um insulin
pumps and stuff there's
so these are things that people get
because they would die without
they also have wireless connections in
them so you can control them
because you can't go in the body so
people have hacked them
and if someone's got like a pacemaker
and you hack it you can
do things too that's horrible right
so the same thing with insulin pumps i
went to i think i was at defcon which is
the hecker convention
and there was someone doing a demo of
how they could wirelessly hack an
insulin pump and
you just kill somebody so imagine you
have a neural link
and elon musk is going to be encrypted
and i'm like oh come on encrypted will
be cracked and then what
and they're going to keep playing the
encryption race i'm not going to be the
guinea pig
yes just to link my brain to the network
so that someone when someone cracks the
latest encryption
they get access to my brain in any
capacity i don't care for what reason i
don't care if they're reading my vitals
you know they can learn from your vitals
they can learn a lot about what you're
doing
they're going to be like looking at
their phone going huh seamus is pooping
nah that's okay that's my private time
you know when i read the news
you leave me alone but facebook knows
just without even doing any of that
stuff
because they can just they know
everything you're doing whenever you're
doing it and your location
like we're already getting that point
and so i'll tell you this
you know what you know what maybe maybe
the answer is who cares just nor link
you know why
we're already being manipulated what why
why does twitter send me these random
tweets you ever
you ever get this thing where it's like
so and so liked this and it just shows
you and it's like
donald trump does a backflip off the
white house i'm like oh man
so i really do think uh i i think a
better way to put it is what michael
malus said actually
he said some really bad people got data
on how much we're willing to it to take
so that's fascinating so they know they
can do certain things
because they know how we behave and
they'll do whatever they want until we
reach that line and then
they'll dance right back you know off of
it but
my main point about neurolink is the
things you see on facebook the algorithm
it's going to shape what you want to do
when you want to do it
i mean there was i was reading something
about studies where it said like a
certain color room will have a certain
effect on you
like a red room will make you angrier a
blue room will calm you down a yellow
room makes you hungry
or is more likely to so what happens if
facebook decides you know those colored
boxes that appear with text in them
what if they say we're going to show
only the red ones to the antifa people
and so they're inundated by all this red
and black and they're just constantly
like
like angry even simpler um with a neural
net you could have someone see like a
red
haze over everything a red filter and
then they would get desensitized
wouldn't even realize they're looking
through red and it might change their
subconscious behavior i don't know what
to what extent neural link could
actually
alter your brain alter the way you see
they say it's going to make you see an
infrared
and and what i'm sure yeah there's i'm
sure there's so much over promising with
that too though
he did say he was going to re re-launch
and land rockets and he made it happen
like in three years yeah
that's true and he's building the
starship tomorrow is he's building it
so i'll tell you what man you know what
i want
i want to play skyrim or whatever the
next elder scrolls is yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna sit in my chair and
i'm gonna you know press the button and
just like donk out
and then i'm going to be in you know
dude you'll be able to play like six
don't do it
don't do it tim i wonder yeah so that's
interesting imagine if we could get to
again
extremely theoretical but if we could
get to a point where you could read
somebody's thoughts or at the very least
detect what kind of mood they're in
and then you could sort of peek in and
examine what mood they are in when
certain concepts are being explained to
them
then you'd be able to evaluate their
political views or whether or not they
hold perspective if you consider to be
unsavory
that's scary yeah but what's awesome is
if you're playing skyrim and then you
forget you're playing skyrim and you
start playing another game with your
skyrim character and you're in the other
game
you're like you're i think people would
lose their mind i don't think people's
psyche can handle that
they would think that they were in a
video game once they were outside of the
video game
guys guys you're in the game right now
no stop i'm telling you keep telling me
that
i think you're right no way
have you guys there's this really funny
comic where it's a
there's like a guy open to bag and
there's a silica gel packet in it have
you have you guys
you know silica gel packets no so when
you when you buy like a piece of
equipment there's a packet it's a silica
gel it absorbs absorbs moisture
okay it says silica gel do not eat and
so the first panel shows him like
opening the bag and he sees it
and then he and then he looks at it and
he goes big silica's not gonna tell me
what to do and he throws it in his mouth
then the next panel is him like a
shocked face and then the last panel is
him with a hat on with like wires coming
out of it and he's in a like a hospital
and there's two doctors saying
congratulations
you've escaped the simulation i saw that
really good no that is very funny i saw
that one that corrected me
that's not telling me what to do when he
eats it i love it
i wonder if we're being controlled from
a distance i don't think in what way
like our brains are
electromagnetically being told what how
to pull on our muscles like
we got these these jellyfish creatures
in us like the brain and brain
is the best floating in the this meat
sack that's basically where we are is
the brains in the brainstem
this creature that's like with
electrical impulses pulls on the muscles
i think that seeing the brain is too
separate from you though i mean like
we're a body soul composite and your
brain
is part of you your brain is not the
separate thing and all of you is you one
creature
like all of you is you though is it man
yeah i believe
pulling on me i don't know man haven't
you ever heard stories about how like
when people get organ transplants
and then all of a sudden they like get
memories or they like pick up behaviors
i don't know if anything that's there's
yeah i have no clue there's neurons in
your stomach
but definitely it's more than your brain
because there's they have neurons and
other muscles i don't even know i
i but but i guess you're sort of boiling
it down to neurons are you and i would
say you extend
beyond neurons so like is there
something out there that's you that's
telling your neurons how to behave or
maybe not maybe out there maybe
i mean i believe in a soul and i believe
that we're a body soul composite so i
wouldn't limit
me to just my brain and say that my body
is something separate from it or that my
soul i think
i think you are all of it i think i
figured it out bro oh no the answer to
everything what is it
we're not it's not a simulation that
we're in we're in a video game
all right your soul is actually
you like you're playing the video game
right and heaven
is when you beat the game and you get
the awards after the game is over
and that's what the point of the game is
high score baby make as much money hoard
it all oh my goodness
oh my goodness i got more points than
you different different goals for
different people because some people
want to have the best body some people
want to have the most money now some
people want to
know the most people you can listen you
can play skyrim
and level yourself up to level 99 and
still not beat the game but it's like
it's like the sims
have you played the sims different sims
have different aspirations sure sure but
let's say let's say
you right now are adding uh you know uh
donald trump's legacy
if that's the video game it's called
president trump that's the video game
and you're right now at a competition
to beat the game the fastest to win the
award or whatever and in order to beat
the game you got to do a bunch of things
and instead you're sitting around
talking about
what space and neural links and whatever
and
and they're saying the point of the game
you win when you break you know 10
million
points and you're saying you're not even
trying to get 10 million people why do
you get the points though
it's money 10 minutes is that it is this
the meaning of life is money
just collect as much money as possible
oh thank god
currency got it that'd be so horrible
before when was currency invented
40 000 no not that long ago someone
invented currency it didn't used to
exist yeah well i mean
well but people have developed currency
in isolation too though it was not
exactly like
john q currency invented it and then we
started using it after i think
in some places they used shells and
other beads or i think different kinds
of flowers is just something that the
people perceived as scarce and valuable
and it became a a common medium of
exchange you know what is the future
currency
electricity they actually call it
currency
electrical current it's currency no i
don't think so
i think energy is the basis for the
value of a lot of currency though
i mean so so you think about why does a
dollar have value and then you try and
determine what what is the value
what are the living wage and what does a
person deserve and
the value of a dollar is tied to what
you can get for it yeah
and it comes down to energy so human
labor is extremely expensive
extremely expensive so we started
replacing human labor over and over
again throughout history right
very early on in human existence human
labor was everything a human would build
a human would pull a human would drag
stuff
then we were like yo that big thing with
hooves is bigger than me
let's tie stuff to it make it carry it
and then it would and then we started
using animal energy
then we started learning about you know
burning carbon for energy
we've continually improved the different
sources of energy and how to manipulate
the energy
and so i guess uh based on like the
petrodollar and stuff and the way
war works and oil the basis of our
currency is very much so
energy return so it's mostly oil
right why does someone want any money
because the oil you can get for you can
use to build
and you don't need humans like the
amount of energy in compared to like
what a human can produce
versus what a machine can do lifting
like
we see the i love ancient aliens and
they talk about like how did humans
possibly live these giant stones and
they they could it was i watched this
really cool one
where this dude he like took it was a
gigantic like
multi-ton stone and he hammered a wooden
wedge under it
and then started rocking it back and
forth and then he dug a hole and then it
flipped over
and he was like that's how you do it you
use its own weight and you apply very
little energy to wobble it
if you had a crane you could just move
it up just like that
so if you have the oil you don't need
the people so the energy coming is is
way more valuable
so we've we've been replacing human
labor with machine labor
and that's the problem that's the
industrial revolution had riots
and there's going to be you know like
like and a free energy riot
maybe i mean the conspiracy theory is
that free energy we've
or or some form of it at least in our
system it would be equivalent to free as
far as we're concerned
is being withheld because it would lead
to widespread riots and discord and
collapse and we don't want it to happen
i don't think i believe that yeah
because that's just like out there but i
mean
the idea makes sense so people believe
it whether or not they have evidence
but uh andrew yang talks about how
automation is going to be the next
industrial revolution
people are going to lose their jobs
because we're going to replace them with
more efficient systems
and we don't need the energy they can
produce because it's dramatically less
than the computer the computer takes a
little bit of energy and it can do 10
times you just tap the thing boop boop
boop and i got my cheeseburger with
extra you know ketchup or whatever
talking to the person man that's a lot
of that's all andrew yang suggested that
we get
every cop a black a blue belt no it was
a purple belt in jiu jitsu and our
police officers should
to study jiu jitsu yeah but then they're
gonna they can't even do chokeholds
yeah yeah i think my thing is yeah i
think my thing with there being a second
industrial revolution because of our
technology is that
i mean in the long run yes there were
problems and there were some pretty
short-term hiccups and serious ones i
don't mean to delegitimize those or say
there weren't actual problems but in the
long run
we have benefited immensely from the
industrial revolution so a second
technological revolution would probably
be very good for us at least materially
speaking
short-term they're afraid of the
short-term chaos yeah they're afraid of
the short-term case and probably
wondering how we could mitigate that
which i think is probably
a fair concern if we really get to that
point i don't know if i bind the idea
that we are going to get to the point
where human labor is so
um unnecessary that we will have these
rides but maybe
i don't know that's why humans need
skills yes something you can do beyond
what the machines can do and so that's
why i think a lot of people are like
college is the answer college is the key
but college doesn't work that way it
doesn't give people these skills
it actually hurts them it gives
administrators jobs yeah
and like improving on your own body is
pretty fun because no computer can do
that for you
i think it's funny how they they you
know i hear from some of these so many
of these comedies they're like don't you
want to live like how star trek was
and i'm like but that's not what you're
doing yeah exactly i love that like just
referencing science fiction and being
like wouldn't that be great
look at this fantasy of something that's
never happened that somebody imagined to
be great wouldn't that be great
yes i got into an argument with with a
dsa person who was saying
like don't you want to live like star
trek and i said sure once we have
replicators and we're post scarcity we
can have a conversation about how our
government works
and they said dude scarcity doesn't
exist wow and i was like
what did like have we cured every cancer
okay then clearly the treatments that
exist are scarce in fact some of them
don't even exist
and they didn't they didn't get like nah
man you just propaganda and i'm like do
you think
i actually i i kid you not i said do you
think the hospital has a cure for all
diseases yes
it's conspiracy theory stuff they think
they think it's
ever say the movie elysium i'm familiar
with the concept it's like the
giant ring floating in space where all
the rich people live and they all speak
french and all the poor people speak
spanish
and the movie's predicated upon this
idea that rich people have these
machines
that would you go and it cures you of
all element and they just won't give it
to the poor people
don't share it because they're big jerks
and exactly and then they
they like a bunch of ships like crash
into elysium
and then they're like now we're going to
reset the system and then everyone can
have stuff
and then they send all the the pods down
and then everyone gets cured yay because
how many pods were there and how many
people were there they never really
answered that question
that they should do an after credit
scene where it's like everything's
destroyed
and everyone's suffering now and now
there's just nothing there's no rich
people there's no there's no cure for
anything no one can get cured
congratulations you burnt it to the
ground
because how are you no you you're right
i was much less interesting than
whatever you were gonna
okay well um don't put that much faith
in her but i appreciate it yeah
even if we did reach a point where
society was like star trek and you could
fabricate any material thing in some
kind of replicator
there would still be a scarcity of time
you would still only have so much on the
planet so scarcity will literally never
disappear scarcity will always exist
it always exists there's only so much
time here on this planet for and it's
not just that unless we have
god-tier powers where we can manipulate
reality
we are not going to a point where we've
solved every problem problems will
always exist
think about it this way let's say humans
are immortal completely immortal all
right
now we're immortal beings we can fly we
can shoot laser beams out of our eyes we
have all these powers
and then one day ian is like yo i'm
going to go to alpha centauri i'll be
back for lunch
and he bursts off into this into fly
away and then
meteor hits him smack ian explodes into
a million pieces we're like no
you guys might be doing that and then
the new th hold on then the new cycle
comes out and they're like the problems
of meteors crashing into our cities
needs to stop and then they need to
solve the problem and then they create
force fields and then the force fields
you know
there's always going to be something
until we can literally just like think
and then
do whatever we want it's never going to
happen there's always any problems we
need problems
and it's not that we need them it's that
we're never even going to get to a point
where we're teleporting and like flying
around and shooting laser beams
it's always going to be like okay we're
immortal now but ian got hit by a bus
we couldn't save him immortal but not
indestructible yeah exactly
biological immortality how much more of
a tragedy would be if someone got killed
by an accident if we were supposed to
live until 10 000.
and it would be inevitable that everyone
would just get killed by an accident at
some point that'd be devastating
um no it is interesting thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time